depuis le début d'année la police de
tours a saisi à peu près 12 kilos de
cannabis et démantèle en moyenne chaque
année six réseaux de trafiquants un
trafic qui a tendance à se diversifier
en direction des drogues dures mais la
principale langue ans ce sont des
consommateurs toujours plus jeunes le
pourcentage des mineurs qui sont
interpellés en tant que consommateurs
usagers de cannabis est en forte
augmentation depuis depuis quelques
années pour vous donner un chiffre
en 2009 la proportion était de 11% sur
l'ensemble des usagers interpellé en
2012 il est passé à 25 % des
consommateurs de cannabis plus jeunes il
suffit de se rendre à la sortie d'un
lycée pour le constater quand le 1er
juin et et fumer il ya une vingtaine
d'années au lycée il est maintenant de
plus en plus fumer au collège quinze ans
un sixième mois je fume pas treize ans à
15 ans 10 16 ans 15 ans et toutes les
catégories sociales sont concernées à
tour les lieux pour se fournir sont bien
connus des forces de l'ordre lé quartier
du sanitas des fontaines et de la
rabière à joué les tours mais aussi le
vieux tours et les quais de la loire
autre phénomène la proportion de thc
contenue dans le cannabis est en hausse
pour deux raisons la déferlante des
productions d'europe du nord et la
multiplication des productions
artisanales à domicile mais saisie
deux pieds de plants de cannabis en
particulièrement augmenté donc on
rencontre de plus en plus des des
personnes qui vont faire pousser du
cannabis chez eux ça va ça peut aller
être un peu en zone rurale mais mais
également en zone urbaine dans des
appartements alors enfin matériel adapté
chaque année c'est une soixantaine
d'affaires liées au cannabis qui sont
traités par le commissariat de tours